l'écran est tout simplement hallucinant
calibration de l'écran c'est ouf
résolution la plus sale affaire hyper
mal
[Musique]
mais saga plats ne sont pas le zoo
planait son cas ne sont pas les emplois
sont bons mais pas tout le monde lit
deux places au beacon la paume 1 place
aux ampoules à campozano police bègles
tampa bay tout seul mais ce domaine
aujourd'hui à paris qu' on est devant
les locaux de one + france pour
découvrir un peu les nouveaux sont pas
les emplois ne sont pas les açores pour
ma part tout le monde sa marine c'est
quoi c'est quoi ces quatre ils sont là
derrière en carton pas mal c'était
l'amour voilà à mais vous avez arrache 5
mai vous avez reçu des messages envoyés
papy c'est nous qui les attend et
utilise un autofocus du cher ouais je
sais faire l'homme courage je fais
confiance je fais confiance
one plus de sortir le 14 enfin présenté
en tout cas le 14 mai prochain deux
nouveaux smartphones one + 7 ou en plus
cette procédure mais c'est plus une
grande nouveauté tout le monde le sait
ça affûté de tous les côtés donc deux
nouveaux smartphones que je viens de
découvrir qu'ils sont juste là que j'ai
pris en main alors j'ai regardé vite
fait je vais la garder davantage à nous
alors l'idée aujourd'hui c'est pas de
vous les présenter parce qu'ils sont
sous embargo jusqu'au 14 août et jusqu'à
la présentation j'ai absolument pas le
droit de vous les présenter par contre
je vais prendre le temps de les
découvrir il faut le faire avec vous
comme ça vous et pour votre patron alors
on va commencer tout de suite par le one
+ 7
je regarde ce qu'on voit pas voilà là
vous voyez absolument rien ils ont
vraiment fait un objet qui est bien
l'autre et est complètement dingue hein
mais celui-là et est vachement bien
ça va
tu es bon sens font affaire inquiète
mois chez moi y'a pas de souci ça va
revenir les toits génial moi ça vous ça
vous dérange que le haut tout là en ont
mais moi je non mais moi je m'en fous
mais dans kung fu en plus au micro riace
directionnelle donc et pas inaperçu
là je suis sur le wan +7 ça c'est
nouveau c'est vachement bien c'est plus
grands la prise en main est super cool
alors je sais que c'est un peu frustrant
qu'un exercice parce que en fait je peux
absolument pas vous vous montrez ce que
je vois il est juste en dessous là il
est juste là la face aux léopards de
vous le montrer mais le one + 7 est
vraiment cool c'est pas un truc
révolutionnaire mais c'est vraiment un
truc qui est qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool où j'en regarde
un peu ce parce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
d'un point de vue logiciel bombe à
oxygène vrai ça vous vous en douterez on
retrouve des choses qu'on collait déjà
sur une plus mais bien je regarde
l'écran pouce de luminosité à fond et
vachement cool c'est un truc qui est
vachement bien mais le gros truc qui a
un peu plus what the fuck
c'est l'autre ou à une puce 7 pro là je
vais le prendre là je sais je sais je
veux bien vous l'avouer là par contre on
est dans autre chose c'est fade de chez
fat j'aimerais bien pouvoir vous décrire
en fait ce que je vois mais j'ai pas le
droit
donc je sais vous en voyez quel intérêt
c'est vraiment partager ça parce que je
ne peux pas vous le dire mais vous
pouvez voir la tronche ça peut être pas
mal
c'est le truc assez ouf l'écran et c'est
c'est je bluffe pas quoi le truc est
vraiment what the fuck
je pousse la lumière un fond c'est
complètement ouf et surtout la grosse
nouveauté c'est ça la alors ça vous
pouvez pas le voir mais ouais je vous
dise pas le truc qui a une fonction qui
est vachement bien ils ont fait un truc
logiciel au niveau du doubs qui est
vachement bien vous livrer quand on en
repart avec 14 ans vous êtes à vous
abonner comme ça vous vous saurez tout
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
intéressant non il ya vraiment eu un
beau boulot logiciel et du point de vue
matériel au niveau de la caméra comment
ça marche c'est rick nash pour y passer
la journée 3
ah j'adore ça fait un peu comme dans
l'ue si vous avez regardé les visiteurs
à l'époque c'est une journée aujourd'hui
je pourrais me amusé pendant des heures
j'adore je trouve ça vachement bien à
l'arrière le toucher vraiment canon
smartphone est vraiment bien c'est cool
parce que one + a toujours été sur le
sens du flagship killer avec des
smartphones vraiment vraiment
intéressant cette année c'est un truc un
peu différent et c'est vraiment en
taxant noah paraît un peu plus tard
parce que vous avez au final de produits
qui sortent donc je peux pas vous
définir l'adn de chaque produit vous
savez mais s'appelle pro donc on se dit
qu'on est un peu car elles ont plus
premium
j'expliquerai s'arrêter pendant quelques
temps mais on encore un palier qui est
qui et qui vraiment franchi avec ce
smartphone et ouais on va on va encore
encore encore encore plus loin c'est
c'est vraiment cool
les deux produits sont bien le one + 7
est vraiment vraiment vraiment
intéressant le one + 7 pro il lui envoie
vraiment du bois l'écran est tout
simplement hallucinant calibration de
l'écran c'est ouf résolution ça va faire
hyper mal c'est deux produits qui vont
être vraiment vraiment top et je pense
que le one + 7 pro pas vraiment faire
très très mal que tu sais ce que c'est
ça
je soupçonne
ouais je prends tu penses que c'est quoi
est-ce qu'il faut que je le dise tu veux
quand je dis que c'est un magnifique
sept exactement
donc il est là dans mon sac elle
n'espérait pas le croiser en ville avec
parce que même quand j'aurais tourné
cette vidéo il va être au choix une
bonne planque il bougera pas mais l'a
pour l'instant je me balade dans paris
ce smartphone mon pote très discret donc
je vais arrêter d'en parler comme sa
famille la guillotine est question voilà
pour cette découverte du diwan plus ça
témoigne plus est pro je vous en reparle
très très prochainement parce que les
smartphones vont être présentés comme je
le disais le 14 mai à londres
j'emmène avec moi dans les bagages dont
je vous invite dès maintenant vous
abonner pour l'instant moi je vais aller
le tester je vais aller l'ouvrir g20 les
jeunes boxer je vais tout préparé et
puis je vous dirai dans quelques jours
dès lors le droit de vous en parler je
vous dirai ce que j'en pense désolé
j'aurais aimé vous ne pouvoir vous en
montrer plus mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible je vais quand même
partager cette expérience avec vous de
découverte
donc voilà je sais pas si ça vous
intéresse et si vous voulez qu'on fasse
ça allait venir
l'idée est justement de pouvoir parler
d'un produit comme ça quand il va sortir
avant qu'ils sortent comme l'a dit moi
ce que vous en pensez si vous avez hâte
qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir comme le steak et comme
fonctionnalité principale pour ses
smartphones
david a marqué tout ça et je vous rendez
vous dès demain j'embrasse 15
[Musique]